[Música]
mi papá era español llegaba cada día a
las seis de la tarde mi casa dejaba la
llave sobre la mesa de la cocina me
abrazaba fuerte y caminábamos muchos
metros hasta llegar al 'tie lo que nos
prestaba su sombra y ahí nos sentábamos
mi papá mi perrita y yo es que me
gustaba tanto que mi papá me contara
cuentos más de uno cada vez
el de la bruja tercera la luz mala eran
mis preferidos pero había uno que me
hacía volar y realice en el país de las
maravillas' ese cuento tenía un no sé
qué que se lo pedía que me lo repita
muchas y muchas veces es que alicia caía
en una madriguera en un viaje infinito
y encontraba personajes insólitos en
lugares increíbles donde la invitaban a
las no fiestas pero había un personaje
de ese cuento que me hacía volar en el
sombrerero loco él estaba invadido
totalmente de la realidad
lo único que lo conectaba con el mundo
era su sombrero mágico era capaz de
hacer conexiones entre los dos mundos
y así crecí contándome una y otra vez el
cuento de alicia en el país de las
maravillas'
pasaron los años y el conejo me arrastro
a mi a su madriguera en el año 2009
tuve que vivir un viaje ciegamente y
desconocido todo por mí acompañada por
el conejo porque el cáncer vino a
visitarme
fue tan importante para mí ese momento
que decidí vivir ese cuento una vez más
acompañado por todos los personajes de
ese cuento logré terminar con esto de
una forma definitiva
en el año 2009 internet no era lo que
era hoy no tenía muchas opciones y lo
único que sabía es que el oncólogo me
había dicho que si tenía quimioterapia
me iba a quedar pelada y yo dije yo
pelada no me quedo de ninguna manera sé
que para una mujer quedarse sin una teta
y pelada es poner la autoestima por el
piso no estaba dispuesta a eso entonces
empecé a investigar muy lento internet
muy poca información pero encontré que
en el 2009 una empresa de holanda estaba
investigando que se congelaba el
folículo del pelo podía hacer que el
pelo no se cayera inmediatamente dije
manos a la obra esto es mío con un
montón de amigos nos pusimos a trabajar
en esto y nos ponía hielos en la cabeza
en bolsas de nylon que se derretía se me
corría el maquillaje y uno de ellos que
corría me dice por qué no pruebas con
los geles azules que son para golpes y
torceduras que se ponen en el freezer y
quedan maleables quedan congelados y ahí
fui
y ahí fui y construir esto que me
acompañó durante todas mis
quimioterapias
este invento maravilloso que logra que
todas las personas que estén transitando
la quimioterapia puedan pasarlas con su
pelo
este casco maravilloso se mete en el
freezer se congela menos 20 grados
centígrados y nos acompaña durante toda
la quimioterapia
este casco se usa 30 minutos antes de
que inicie el tratamiento luego se
utiliza y se cambia cada 30 segundos a
lo largo de todo el tratamiento y se
deja una hora más o sea dos cascos más
esto provoca una vasoconstricción y una
hibernación de los folículos de pelo
permitiendo así que no se caiga esto
maravilloso porque para todos los
pacientes oncológicos quedarse pelado es
ver la gravedad de lo que nos está
pasando cuando no puede transitar con
pero la enfermedad todo cambia mi
oncólogo que no creía en mí cuando vine
con este invento fue el primero que me
apoyó y pasé mis 12 sesiones de
quimioterapia con este pelo feliz y
contenta y él empezó a difundirlo entre
sus propios pacientes y fue el tiene una
mano más grande me dio armó un hospital
de día en él se me de buenos aires lo
pintamos de color naranja y él consiguió
lo freezer para que todas las personas
que se hacían su quimioterapia pueden
usar sus cascos el sombrero loco una vez
me había acompañado pero en el camino
encontré un montón de personajes
por ejemplo la oruga azul que me decía
es tan importante cuidar tu pelo no es
más importante cuidar tu vida y hay un
montón de personas preocupadas que no te
pongas eso que es mejor salvar tu vida
que esto es una frivolidad nadie
entendía lo que es que te miren raro y
que te miren como enfermo cuando estás
transitando el cáncer
y esto no va a quedar así dije yo porque
si yo pude conservar mi pelo para algo
vino al cáncer a decírmelo y me puse
automáticamente a ver cómo podía
trascender este invento y arme un
facebook que se llama quimio con pelo
paula estrada y empezaron a llover
mensajes de todo el mundo recibí 10.000
mensajes en un día fue una cosa
impresionante y yo dije esto esto no lo
puedo guardar entonces hice un instagram
y sin facebook y empezaron a ayudarme un
montón de chicas y ahí lo que hago es
ayudar y acompañar a todas las personas
que están transitando esta enfermedad
a que puedan estar mejor y más felices
con su pelo y llevar estos cascos
puestos además hace que se genere una
comunidad de amigos porque necesitamos a
alguien que nos ayude a ponernos lo y
siempre digo que ponerse el casco como
cambiar la rueda en fórmula uno
uno necesita un asistente que le pone el
casco en las piernas mientras tiene el
otro puesto y en sólo tres segundos
tiene que sacar y poner porque nunca
puede estar el folículo del pelo sin
frío este casco llega a menos 20 grados
centígrados y el proceso de hibernación
y demás contricción sucede si y sólo si
nos sacamos en todo el tratamiento el
casco hay cientos de miles de personas
que ya lo están usando y hemos tenido la
suerte que en abril del 2017 la efe idea
americana haya aprobado este invento y
en eeuu se está usando en muchos
hospitales públicos ojalá también acá en
argentina puede ser seguir difundiendo
se y también me encontré con el conejo
que seguía preguntándome para qué estaba
parada y seguía diciéndome que no me
quedara así solamente haciendo esto
y ahí fue cuando con una de mis ahijadas
porque llamamos así a las personas que
asistimos la llamamos ahijadas con ella
armamos un whatsapp donde hay miles y
miles de hombres y mujeres que están
transitando la enfermedad y lo que
descubrimos es que empatizamos desde lo
que nos está pasando a veces es difícil
contar que uno tiene cáncer porque la
persona intenta ponerse en su lugar pero
no puede saber lo que nos está pasando
en cambio en ese grupo tenemos todas
mujeres y hombres que están transitando
el mismo momento entonces hablamos de un
montón de cosas nos recomendamos cosas
para hacer recetas y nos recomendamos
también algunas algunas cosas sexuales
para hacer porque perdemos la autoestima
por un rato pero no perdemos nunca las
ganas de amar
y así hace ya más de 10 años que estamos
con estos cascos acompañando a todos y
tengo un grupo de mujeres maravillosas
que son ahijadas donde compartimos
experiencias compartimos momentos y
podemos decir que somos una familia no
de sangre pero sí de experiencias sí de
momentos compartidos sí de escucha
totalmente comprometida hacia los otros
y ante todo decimos siempre que
aprendimos a reírnos de no tener una
teta o ningún ovario pero tenemos unos
bien grandes y unas ganas
enormes de sentirnos vivas
la quinta pata del gato no existe
simplemente todos estamos un poco locos
muchas gracias